c'est une chaîne de conditionnement de
bouteilles de vin qui a été touché la
moitié de la toiture du bâtiment a été
détruite les caves
elles ont été épargnés c'est en milieu
de nuit que l' alerte a été donnée
c'est parti a priori très vite les
voisins ne s'en soient pas aperçus tout
de suite puisque ben ça tu prends dans
des tasses a dû à l'enquêté d'encours
prendre dans l'étape carton ça a couvé à
l'intérieur et quand cette partie c'est
enlever le toit c'est à ce moment là que
les voisins l'ont vu et c'était déjà
bien parti bien parti pour le moment
c'est rien du tout on sait seulement que
les pompiers étaient nombreux donc
souvenirs deux grandes échelles
une de dijon et de beaune et puis toutes
les casernes de la course était présente
avec les moyens aussi dont il y avait du
monde pour l'instant l'origine du
sinistre n'a pas été déterminé la
gendarmerie attend maintenant les
résultats des différentes expertises
trop tôt également pour chiffrer les
temps du fait des dégâts à sinistre qui
ne devrait cependant pas avoir
d'incidence sur l'une des périodes de
plus forte activité de l'année les
vendanges
elle s'annonce d'ailleurs plutôt précoce
cette année